you have to do something for 10 minutes
minimum
if you don't have 10 minutes you don't
have a life usually before the sun comes
up
i offer myself to something greater than
myself
i cannot explain the power that i get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses
and being in control wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
foreign
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to change
your morning routine to start your day
with success enjoy
let's kick it off with rule number one
meditate with oprah winfrey
usually before the sun comes up i offer
myself
to something greater than myself
if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10
minutes
i at least stop in that space in my
house every morning
i have a little meditation space where i
just go
i have beautiful spiritual readings
there i
light my three candles there daily word
or
something and i express to this greater
energy field than i
that i don't want to be alone as i move
out into the world rule number two
prime yourself with tony robbins i teach
people
that daily you have to prime yourself
you have to do something for
10 minutes minimum if you don't have 10
minutes you don't have a life
and ooh that's so good i mean i just
like you've got to do it right that's
good
if you don't have 10 minutes you don't
have life to give to priming yourself
that's right prime life you want a
beautiful life a beautiful family
i'm so i'm so i i i love that you know
what i do the first time i wake up in
the morning yeah
people always ask me how do you sew up
all the time but part of i attend all
these seminars you know i teach all this
but the real reason is you prime
yourself i prime myself that's what i've
done for years it's like
i've changed my body this radical
breathing pattern or movement there's
many ways to do it
but then i do 10 minutes and i do it
usually goes more because i'm enjoying
it
yeah but ten minutes is how i get myself
to do it three and a half minutes of
pure gratitude about three things
and i take one of those three to be
simple because i don't want to be the
astronaut that
you know he went to the moon that was
his idea adventure and then they all
come back and we're depressed because
what do i do for the rest of my life
yes so the wind on my face you know my
children's faces
um anything and the reason for gratitude
is the two emotions that mess us up the
most
are fear and anger yeah and you can't be
grateful and fearful simultaneously they
don't go together
and you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously so if you
literally start your day cultivating
that this part is talking about creating
a highway to happiness yeah
and then i do three minutes of my three
to thrive what are three
outcomes and results i'm really
committed to and i see them as done
and fulfilled and then for that day i
usually look at something at six months
to 12 months out
something is a little bigger and then
what i feel is fulfilled and done
i give thanks for it and you're at the
end of those 10 minutes and usually it's
15 or 18 for me
i am so wired now i've done that for
years it's been the base of me
what's different with suffering is
measuring it moment to moment oprah
and then the third one for me is okay
how do i love more because love to me is
an action
it's not a word it's not an emotion it's
like if you love you act accordingly so
love
and what can i do in a loving way and
that what can i be grateful for and that
little three-step process
ends the suffering rule number three
start your day
in control with mel robbins you must
come up with a morning routine
that you do every single morning
or at least more mornings than not that
puts you
in control of yourself and in control of
your day
this is what i do and i cannot
explain the power that i get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses
and being in control first and foremost
wake up on time when that alarm goes off
get your butt out of bed five four three
two one go
why is that important for persistence
the reason why
is because the first decision that
you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means
you are persistently bigger
than your excuses you are persistently
bigger than feeling lazy and you are
persistently beating the feelings that
typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start
surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed and
you know team stream and checking out
the sales on zappos and looking at your
facebook news feed before you pick up
the damn phone
please please please figure out your two
priorities for the day
these are the things that matter to you
whether it's saving money and and making
sure you're focused on that
or showing up at work and being a
contributor
or whether it's changing how you treat
your spouse or your kids or the person
that you're with
or heck getting to the gym because you
said you would
whatever it is that your two priorities
are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why
the reason why is because of persistence
the reason why is because i want you to
have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day
is snoozing starting your day off late
starting your day off tired starting
your day off by
mainlining everybody else's news feed on
social media
and looking at everybody else's life and
and saying to yourself oh my god they're
on vacation or gosh they look so great
or
their friends are so fancy or my gosh
they've got some money
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day
you gotta start off your day by getting
up on time figuring out your priorities
and then getting to work on them
do not pick up your phone until you have
done those two things
i think the single biggest reason why
people have bad days
is because they start them off by
looking around at everybody else and
seeing what they're doing
instead of having the focus and the
discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center
so you want a bonus round exercise every
day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise
you do those three things you'll be
kicking ass every single day
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief the link
to join
absolutely for free is in the
description below
so if you want to change your life my
friends you got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus
it's about what you're saying to
yourself but it also comes at work
so whenever i was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
i was going through
just saying you know i would put you
know you can't hurt me
the key that the key to i think being a
good
business leader is is your is how good
you are with people
rule number four exercise with richard
branson do you think you do so well in
business
because you're dedicated to looking
after your body and leading an active
lifestyle
a hundred percent i think if you can
find an hour or two a day for yourself
uh for your body then you're going to be
able to do
you know five or six more hours of
creativity throughout the day
and and we all know you know when we let
ourselves go
you know we're we're just not going to
perform as well so
you know one of the reasons we set up
health clubs
in pretty well every you know all the
major cities around the world is
um you know is is it is a passion of
mine i think
it's so important that people you know
um keep healthy
rule number five win against yourself
with david goggins
what's your morning routine every
morning without fail the first thing i
do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016.
okay so i get up i do that four days out
of the week i go to the gym
and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours
that was the killer part of the book
every night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time
set aside to quiet and recover
recovery is big the mind especially the
mind and the body
this is my time there's no phone calls
there's no emails
the world does not exist because i have
to get ready for tomorrow
get the body opened up why because as i
won't get you know
two years you went deeper it was awesome
but your body's getting tight yeah you
go hard tom yeah a lot of people go hard
what happens is that stress
yep starts to tighten up that psoas
muscle hip flexors so
lower back you got back problems all of
a sudden you have no idea
why it's all tightness it's all
tightness man because you're constantly
charged and going hard and rule number
six the last one before a very special
bonus clip
is wake up early with dwayne johnson
four o'clock in the morning i wake up
have my caffeine o'clock in the morning
four o'clock in the morning but by the
way that's the magic hour that four
o'clock in the morning is when no one
else is up so no one else is bothering
you
and you can focus on whatever work you
have to get done i'm sending these
electronic mails
those things right i've heard those
things
uh and then by 4 30 4 45 i'm doing some
sort of cardio
so in this case i come out here open
these garage doors
uh it's still dark outside so it's just
me and a whole bunch of
blair witch things that are happening
out there in the woods
and i jump on this thing i do this and
then i'll have breakfast and then i will
go do all my strength and conditioning
training at a gym
for about an hour and then i'll go to
set so total workout time for all the
dudes that are like
i could look like that at home right now
yeah how much run time cardio and
strength do you do a day
between cardio strength and resistance
training
stretching maybe about an hour and 45
minutes
okay that's not too bad not too bad too
bad it's not all in one shot
okay you have to be watching your diet
because we know diet like they say abs
are made in the kitchen
so more than you're working out diets
everything i can tell you right now
is just to find balance as well okay so
it's a little bit of everything yeah
sure so i think carbs are your friend
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated inspired
you have a 35 chance of following
through but when you get motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you at what
time do you get up normally in the
morning
uh for me it's usually about seven seven
okay um but i go to bed late so usually
it's
i go to bed around one a.m or so one day
yeah
and you start today with a real
breakfast or just for the coffee or with
the water
you know that also varies a lot um i i
think it's probably true that if you
that having a good breakfast
is is a good idea but um usually i don't
have time for that so um
sometimes uh sometimes it's it's made
for me but
um probably half the time i don't have
any breakfast i had to
have like coffee or something like that
and a mars bar with it once for sure
well
i'm trying to cut down on the on on
sweet stuff so
um but i think i mean i think i probably
should have like a
an omelette and a coffee or something
like that that seems like probably the
right thing and sometimes i do have that
[Music]
if you want to know the 10 habits that
you need to develop
this year check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we were aspiring to be real
warriors
tough battle hardened seals but the
wisdom of this simple act
has been proven to me many times over